we put a lot of hard work into this
that's not just something that just blew
your name on we have unbelievable
dialogue in terms of trying to innovate
the product itself you met Michael in
his 20s who was he then how is he
developed over the years as your partner
Michael Jordan was special the minute I
met him I just can't tell you how amazed
I was at how composed how mature he was
he was already thinking about style and
business you just came from a different
planet and it was magical and that's
from day one he was stylish off the
court he was classy very strong
communicator and I think he somehow
transcended basketball jumped out of the
sport into modern culture
we always want to look at performance
first if a player can't play in the shoe
it's not a good product for us however I
am a storyteller as a designer I tell
stories through the work we tell a lot
of stories and the stories come from
real-life interaction with Michael and
with other people around the world and
somehow they develop a personality how
is his DNA in the product year after
year year after year it's because we
talk to him all the time we test each
other you know he comes up with the idea
and I'm saying well tinker you know that
doesn't play in terms of the way we you
know you play the game about it call me
up the middle night we listen we listen
to what he has to say and certainly we
look at what his likes and dislikes are
and it just just just gets filtered into
the design somehow one thing that we
really have a good handle on is bringing
new and younger people into the process
Michael Jordan created the image based
on performance and being real I think
that's what we see in Russell Westbrook
he is a fantastic player he's very
stylish she looks great in photo shoots
and just walking down the street and he
has charisma he can talk to people and
he seems really interesting and fun and
to me that's how you build a brand in
the world of sneaker heads you are the
Messiah did you ever think Noah
did you ever think this would become a
subculture no I never really thought
that way I just wasn't trying to do a
good job for Michael it just has
happened kind of organically and
certainly we've helped it along but it's
to me that I'm still kind of puzzled I'm
still puzzled by how big it